Cédric et Brunella maillot ont deux
enfants Louan et Joshua depuis moins
d'un an ils ont un nouveau membre dans
leur famille c'est hipsos un toutou un
peu spécial car c'est un chien d'éveil
une réponse que Cédric et Brunella ont
apporté à leurs deux bambins car ils
sont chacun d'eux concerné par plusieurs
handicaps c'était difficile au départ je
pense comme tout le monde parce que tu
as ton monde qui s'effondre pour toi
quand tu sors de l'hôpital c'est noir et
il y a plus rien il y a pas d'espérance
il y a rien du tout et puis après au fur
et à mesure ben tu tu tu te dis ok ben
tu sais pas de quoi demain sera fait
mais alors du coup bah allons donner le
maximum pour le jour J pour le moment
présent et on a commencé à apprécier la
vie qu'on avait avec Louan on a focalisé
sur les bons moments qu'on avait avec
elle sur tout ce qu'elle faisait et pas
sur ce qu'elle faisait pas on on a on a
insufflé beaucoup de bah on croit on
croit en elle en fait on croit au
potentiel qu'elle a en elle on essaie de
se dire comment nous en tant que parent
on va pouvoir lui donner le le maximum
pour maximiser son potentiel et pour ne
pas voir en fait les
limites par la suite c'est de ça quel
est notre projet c'est le commencement
tout ce qu'on a vécu avec Louan tout ce
qu'on a enduré tout ce que elle elle a
elle a vécu qui nous a mis à cœur de
commencer quelque chose pour et d'autre
famill et c'est vrai que le la naissance
de Joshua notre deè deuxè enfant notre
petit garçon ça a fait qu'accentuer ça
leur projet c'est l'association famille
espoir son objectif apporter un soutien
aux familles qui traverse les mêmes
difficultés parmi les activités de
soutien qu'il propose hipsos leur chien
d'éveil fait partie de Cell les plus
originales et surtout exclusive à la
Réunion on avait entendu parler des
chiens d'assistance des chiens d'éveille
on voulait en prendre un pour le petite
fille sauf qu'en s renseignant on s'est
rendu compte qu'il fallait aller en
métropole c'est ça nous demandait
beaucoup trop de contrainte au niveau
des frais de voyage et surtout que LAN
est très réglé donc on se voyait pas à
partir 15 jour en métropole donc on
s'est dit ben qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour acquérir un chien parce qu'on était
convaincu de la zoothérapie des
bienfaits de l'animal sur l'enfant et en
discutant avec notre ami donc Olivier
Cosette qui est vétérinaire au tampon on
s'est dit pourquoi pas mettre pourquoi
pas former le chien nous-même leur ami
est vétérinaire comportementaliste il
décid de leur offrir un en choisi par
ses soins pour démarrer le projet il n'y
a pas cette possibilité auj aujourd'hui
à la réunion très peu de familles ayant
un enfant porteurs d'un handicap peuvent
bénéficier de ce type de chose donc
vraiment ce projet est né de ça en se
disant B on va essayer de mettre en
place toutes les structures localement
depuis l'élevage jusqu'à la production
finale du chien donc éducateur
vétérinaire comportementaliste famille
d'accueil pour arriver à offrir aux
familles réunionnaises des chiens
d'éveil pour les les enfants porteurs de
handicap hipsos est pour eux un
véritable plus à l'accompagnement
médico-social chaque jour il participe à
la stimulation des enfants Louan elle a
les yeux qui pétit quand elle voit son
chien au niveau psychomote ça lui
apporte beaucoup aussi dans pour pour
l'appréhension elle va ouvrir et
refermer donc elle va travailler en fait
sa préhension rien qu'en touchant les
poils du chien quand Ipsos vient la
bousculer un petit peu en lui faisant
des bisous bah elle réagit donc elle a
elle aime son chien et Joshua donc le
bébé notre bébé il il lui c'est pareil
il aime passer sa main dans la fourire
de de hipsos avec un chien il se crée
une véritable relation sociale et bien
sûr quand tout va très très bien dans
une famille dans un environnement les
liens sociaux sont parfaits mais
lorsqu'il va y avoir des tensions ou des
troubles du lien social et bien souvent
le chien va être parce qu'il il a tissé
un lien sociale aussi une relation
sociale une véritable relation avec
l'enfant l'enfant va pouvoir des fois se
confier va pouir lui parler va pouvoir
se rassurer donc il y a vraiment une
relation une interaction qui intervient
et qui permet à l'enfant effectivement
de puiser parfois dans cette ressource
le dressage du chien est adapté aux
enfants pour LAN et Joshua ce compagnon
fera bientôt une parfaite nounou cherche
voilà
amè
allez c'est bien c'est
bien mon ma chérie c'est bien ça ah il
aura les commandements basiques durant
la première année il y aura le assis
coucher pas bouger comme comme tous les
chiens l'apprennent mais ensuite il va
rentrer dans une phase on va essayer d'
d'inculquer des des ures des
commandements qui sont spécifiques à
l'enfant par exemple la Louan elle elle
a elle elle ne parle pas elle ne marche
pas elle tient pas assise donc les
commandements spécifiques qu'on va
essayer de faire rentrer par la suite
c'est aller prendre son bibron par
exemple aller prendre son bibron ramener
aller prendre un jeu ramener rester à
côté de Louan pas bouger pendant des
heures s'il faut sera plus ça pour elle
être à côté et jouer avec elle nous
prendre Louan le mettre sur son dos le
faire garesser et cetera maintenant pour
un enfant qui marche ce sera différent
ce sera l'enfant pourra jouer avec le
chien donc là les les commandements qui
qui vont être inculqués au chien seront
un peu différents tous les chiens ne
peuvent pas s'improviser chien d'éveil
hipsos n'est pas choisi au hasard c'est
un chien équilibré calme et qui a été
préparé sur plusieurs lignes pour avoir
un
chien équilibré on va dire entre
guillemets faut déjà que l'éleveur à la
base travaille bien entendu ces ligné
génétiques avoir les chiens les plus
calmes possibles entre guillemets parce
que après c'est une question d'éducation
aussi on essaie de sélectionner au
maximum les chiens les plus doux poss
possiblebles hipsos est le fruit d'un
projet global un espoir que ce couple
souhaite faire profiter aux familles qui
traversent les mêmes difficultés leur
souhait réunir des fonds pour pouvoir
tout simple donner un chien aux familles
on a pris nous notre chien donc hisos
pour Louan il y a on va prendre un autre
chien dans 2 mois donc la Pée est déjà
est déjà née mais on va le prendre et ce
chien là en fait on va le placer chez
l'éducateur directement chez l'éducateur
canin pendant une dizaine de mois et
c'est l'éducateur CAN qui va lu lui
inculquer les bases du chien et ensuite
on va le passer dans la famille cette
solidarité c'estes projets d'espoir
c'est ce qui a permis à Cédric et
Brunella de surmonter leurs difficultés
la famille maillot innove au travers de
ce projet canin grâce à eux les familles
réonnaises pourront plus facilement
faire profiter leurs enfants des câlins
de ce compagnon
d'éveil